and when we find the zeros what that
means is that we're setting the output
or the Y value equal to zero so you can
see that this is zero equals X minus two
over X plus six now there's a couple
different ways to look at this one way
to look at it is the only way that this
fraction here on the right will be equal
to zero is if the numerator is zero and
that's basically it right so here you
can see that the only way that this
would be zero is if x equals two so you
can see that two is the zero
now when we talk about zeros what that
means is that the Y coordinates 0 so 2
comma zero means that that's an x
intercept okay it's a root 2 solution
and x intercept is 0 these terms are
used interchangeably but basically a 0
means the Y is 0 and the reason it's an
x-intercept is because you're not going
up or down okay you're just going right
to but then the y coordinate is 0 now if
you don't like this method what a lot of
students will do is will say well zeros
like 0 over 1 and what you can do is you
can cross multiply cross that equal sign
okay just like working with a proportion
X plus 6 times 0 is 0 and 1 times
anything is itself and so then when you
solve this equation by adding 2 to both
sides you can see that x equals 2 but
the shortcut is just to set the
numerator to 0 that's how you find the
x-intercepts or the zeros ok now for the
second example what you want to do for
this one is you want to factor the
numerator in the denominator as much as
you can and the reason is is because if
you have a factor in the numerator that
cancels with a factor in the denominator
like you see here X minus 2 you're not
going to actually have a point on your
graph at that point because what happens
is it's actually a hole in the graph or
what they call a removable discontinuity
so in all practical for all practical
purposes these factors are cancelling
one another out and your basic equation
now is going to look like 1 over X plus
2 so here you can see that if you try to
set the numerator to 0 like we did in
this previous example you can't really
set a constant to 0 so what this means
is that there's no zeros there's no
x-intercepts for this particular graph
ok there's going to be a hole and I
talked about that in another video
can check that out of graphing rational
functions but the way you would locate
the hole is the hole will be at two
comma now if you put two in two what's
left over here that's going to be 1/4
but in this case we're just talking
about the zero so let's look at the
third example same thing you want to
factor the numerator ok X minus four X
plus three and you want to factor the
denominator it's a difference of two
squares X minus three X plus three again
notice that these X plus 3s are
cancelling so we're not going to have a
zero at negative three if we set the
numerator to zero we're just going to
have an x intercept at four or a zero at
4 so this graphs going to cross at 4
comma zero right there so I hope this
helped you to understand how to find the
x-intercepts or the zeros when you're
graphing rational functions
subscribe to the channel check out some
more videos at Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon